by studying galaxies like Andromeda one
of the the biggest discoveries I suppose
of the latter half of the 20th century
was made this was a discovery made by an
American astronomer called Vera Rubin
and what Vera Rubin was doing was
looking at stars as they went around the
Andromeda galaxy and other galaxies in
our sort of local neighborhood and what
she found was that the speeds of these
galaxies was far too fast so if you if
you look at the Galaxy what you can see
there is you know stars and dust and gas
if you add up all that visible matter
you can work out how much gravity the
Galaxy should exert and that then tells
you the orbital speed the Stars should
go around it but the stars were going
far faster than they ought to be and
what that meant was that if this was all
the matter there was what the Galaxy
should actually be flying apart the
Stars should all be escaping from the
Galaxy out into into Galactic space and
this is really the sort of convincing
evidence for the existence of what we
now call dark
matter